you
so think of this you may love that
picture from your friend on Instagram
but you may not know if anyone else is
gonna like it
Instagram has been testing hiding lights
in countries like Canada and Australia
so starting this week the company is
expanding the tested parts of the United
States
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Los Angeles
with more on the story
Jonathan this move is not without
controversy good morning to you good
morning to Yelp for users like my mom
who only get about 5 likes per post I
think it's pretty welcome news but
you're right there is controversy for
one rapper Nicki Minaj who's actually
vowing to no longer use a platform she
says among other things removing likes
actually takes away power from
influencers and emerging artists who
want to show how big their fanbase is
but when you talk to the head of
Instagram he says ultimately this is
about users mental health
Adam people live for the likes are you
worried or concerned that that will hurt
your platform taking away the likes a
little worried or not it's happening
making good on a pledge he made to Gayle
King last June Instagram had Adam maseri
is changing the way millions of users
interact with the app you don't want
Instagram to be such a competition we
want it to be a place where people spend
more of their energy connecting with the
people that they love and the things
that they care about friends can still
press that little heart but only the
user who posted the pic will be able to
feel the love Tech writer Taylor Lorenz
this is healthy for users because it
does eliminate some of that tension
around sharing and you know measuring
yourself worth against how many likes
you get on a picture Instagram tried out
the hidden likes feature for months in
Canada Australia New Zealand Ireland
Italy Brazil and Japan and a tweet sent
out by maseri last Friday he announced
the feature was hitting stateside adding
quote looking forward to the feedback
and feedback is already coming Instagram
influencer Kim kardashian-west agrees
the move will be beneficial for people's
mental health but hip-hop artist cardi B
feels the problem isn't the likes but
the comments she made her voice heard on
Instagram even though she didn't want to
show her face guiding the craziest
arguments been starting to raise pain
all because the comments the comments
affect more
than the likes I think people are
freaking out about the removal of likes
because it seems so core to the
Instagram experience Lorraine says the
binary like and dislike is already
outdated maseri agrees we will do things
that mean people use Instagram less if
we think that they keep people safe or
generally create a a healthier
environment I think we have to be
willing to do that
instagrams new CEO has has spoken a lot
about his goals to reduce bullying and
foster a healthy community and I think
this is definitely in line with those
efforts that's ultimately good for
business and another concern being
voiced this will be the end of Instagram
influencers users who profit from having
a huge fan base our expert disagrees she
says Instagram has other analytic tools
to share with influencers and losing
likes won't change the type of
engagement they've already seen Tony all
right what did you do Gayle didn't make
a pledge to me it's something that the
company of course had decided there are
many conversations about it but I think
it's admirable what Adam series is the
message that he's sending yes yep they
could possibly take a hit and people
will be very upset and ticked off about
it he said people's mental health
because there is a and that it has her
young people's mental health and
stability so I admire that they're
taking the yeah clearly with some
reluctance yes meantime Jonathan please
like my photo of my wife I just put it
up yeah good peace thank you very much